the extension on the student loan
repayment pause until the end of august
has given borrowers more time to prepare
but it's also opened up opportunities
for scammers today some critical insight
from a student loan debt scam expert on
what nevada borrowers need to know
we're seeing this every single week
we've even seen a company
spoof another company's 800 number and
it comes up on your caller id as though
it's your lender mary jo terry is a
managing partner at y refi sending out
the alarm of scammers taking full
advantage of confusion borrowers may
have when it comes to their student
loans the biggest one is hey i see you
were previously on auto debit let's
update your bank account information
here's where the confusion comes into
play during the pandemic the cares act
postponed federal loans and repayment no
interest accruing that repayment
extension continues to get pushed back
loan servicers have changed and scammers
are banking on the fact that borrowers
haven't looked at their own accounts
over the past two years in nevada
borrowers have racked up about 26
billion dollars worth of student loan
debt if you are one of those borrowers
terry says you need to go to
studentaid.gov
log in update your profile information
find out who your loan servicer is if
anyone tries to get in contact with you
you know what your balance is and you
won't fall for any of these scams but if
you already have here's what you need to
do right now if you've given out
personal information to the point to
where you feel like somebody could open
a credit card in your name as an example
or some kind of line of credit notify
the credit bureaus you can do it all
online they have 800 numbers just put a
fraud alert it's not going to cost you
anything it's not going to hurt you and
if somebody tries to do something
nefarious you're going to get notified
and again if someone contacts you notify
your loan servicer and remember it's
free to enroll in a federal program the
forms and assistance are free christian
well